la circulation s'intensifie car tout le
monde se dépêche de rentrer avant le
commencement une sincère soit et paris
si vous ne furent chez pas nous vous
conseillons d'évacuer les rues dans ce
sera bientôt la garenne d'or ce message
d'un verte annonce qu'au commencement de
la purge est que retentira la sirène tôt
crime y compris celle d'homicide sera
légal
tous les services d'urgence seront
suspendus tu sais que c'est dangereux ça
ne te rendra pas ton fils tu te sentiras
pas mieux si tu fais ça renonce à ses
petites tu dois rendre il faut soit
votre gouvernement vous remercie de
votre participation
vous avez enfreint une règle secrètes
concernant la pêche ne sauvez personnes
c'est une nuit où on ôte la vie on ne
peut tolérer aucune ingérence qui du
temps au cames la théorie pas de héros
tous les mois
réf donc on se déplace tout se passera
bien
ralentissez pas continuer
pourquoi vous nous avez pas encore tué
mesdames et messieurs un nouveau lot
chiavari fait il s'agit de la dernière
purge de la soirée votre contribution
sera de 200 milles cure joueurs en tenue
je vous prie vous retrouvons au terrain
de chasse
on va voir des bandes armées devant nous
on va en avoir derrière nous tine et on
reste couple et sauver votre peau et
j'emprunte joue de boeuf nature des
fêtes minimes
ils nous ont retrouvé
souvenez-vous des bienfaits de la purge